okay so thanks everyone for the birthday
greetings and Maryann it's your birthday
too that's wonderful um won't ask how
old either of us
is but uh I am in going into a prime
Year of My
Life um now the U I guess the first
question I have is uh uh how many people
have finished problem
one or do we have any data here to show
several people have things to
have have examples of solutions yeah um
I don't have a solution but I have a
proof that the class is infinite you
have a proof that the class is infinite
okay uh what what do other people have
uh with now John nothing nothing nothing
nothing further than what we got yeah so
you're you're you're working with uh who
I don't know yet oh okay uh Mike
basically some result there's several
infinite classes you have some infinite
classes of solutions and and Roger lots
of are you guys working who who's
working who's working together now like
Anil who do you I haven't found
it team yet has anybody here found a a
teammate
yet you two guys
tentatively okay well look uh um that's
that's going to be the hardest problem
of all is figuring out who to work with
is that right um do I have to uh look if
you haven't got a partner by next
Tuesday I'm going to have forced
marriages is here um so uh uh think
about that right you know give that some
give that some attention this just uh
maybe this problem is too easy to to
Merit the the uh you know or or too good
to let somebody else to work on with you
but uh no I think uh uh uh poor Ramsey
here only wants to grade uh n over two
projects instead of
n um and uh also the uh uh discussion
with somebody else I think I'll be
although especi it'll be much more
important on the other problems I still
think I'd like you to work on team so so
get a partner by Next by next Tuesday
unless we've already solved the problem
by the end of the day so any other
partial information from this side of
the
table I kind Andy an approach but I
can't quite see how how to finish it
okay so you've got to start on an
approach and uh we have three people who
have infinite uh uh classes of soltion
soal why don't you explain yours you can
if if you take um any number of sixes
and follow it by a seven that gives you
a a monotonic square
root this oh this is so so for example
uh uh 7 SAR is
49 yeah and then 67 squar is is um let
me
see 449 4 49 isn't that
amazing and 6 4489 sorry
4489 okay and then 6 uh 667 squ 667
squar is is 3 four 28 and the
9 4 4
4889 and Sim you always get to one more
four the number of sixes yeah the same
number of eights as the number of sixes
oh okay so now now uh how do we prove
that in general you can prove that by
induction prove it by induction okay so
so um uh for example um
6667 s is equal to 6,000
+ 4 plus 667 squ is this the way you do
it
yeah um is
um
360 0 0 0
plus now 667 looks awful lot like 23
doesn't
it um and so when you take six times it
um yeah we get a we get a uh actually we
want to take 12,000 * 667 so I want to
multiply this by 12 so that would
be um 12 * 7 is is
84 12 * 6 is 96 carry the 8
is
104 and 12 times same
thing like
that did I do that
right I hope anyway
667 probably it'll be something like
that then 667 squ we happen to know is
444 889
didn't work we we're missing a two in
the okay I got it I I blew something
four
four pocket
calculator otherwise known as a
p okay so what do we got here uh how do
you work this darn thing
clear
does it supposed supposed to do
something when I push
C oh all clear oh
okay all right so now all I got to do is
some calculation now 6,000 squar I'm
pretty sure of that one yeah um is that
going to be okay so now the next one was
12,000 time 6
667 equals
oh I'm I blew
it okay
84 8,000
what
see that's that's a I hate to waste time
on that but uh what's going on here 12
times
667 equal
804 okay so I guess I I carried the
wrong thing
well 7 was 84 okay and then 12 * 6 is
90 maybe 12 * 7 isn't 84 I don't
remember anybody remember what what
these
what's if I if my fundamental subes are
are wrong at the bottom then I can't do
then I'm then I can't do any any problem
solving what's wrong with
this okay so that's okay so this one
anyway we get we get our induction
another eight comes down here and then
um uh lo and behold another another four
comes in there and this uh probably uh
uh can be seen to generalize that that
12 * 667 does the right thing okay so um
it's the 12 * 6 that was my my that was
my faulty sub I was getting 12 * 6 is 96
that's not a very good uh thing to keep
in my mind I got to flush
that okay um all right so so uh we'll
get an inductive proof of of this and
you said you had some more
examples um I was looking you can put I
I think you can put threes in I can read
them all
in front of a five works so you have
what threes thre's in front of a five
okay so three to the N five let's take
for example 3 335 squ is equal to same
pattern with ones twos and the five at
the end how many ones
um let's try 30 35 squ
is is
uh what one one two 25 is it no 122 1 22
1 225
okay and so this is 1 one 1 2
two
cim
okay and another
one well any number of Threes in front
of a four oh yeah or seven or a seven
you mean like this it's going to do
one okay see this is
in fact you can go to any number of
three is followed by any number of six
is followed by seven so interest oh wow
so there we get a okay now that's a real
that's a that one I that one surprises
me these other one I mean I I woke up in
the middle of the night and I said 335
squar is is one
2 and and I I I didn't go the next step
but but uh you can say any number of
Threes followed by any number of sixes
followed by a a what oh wow so it's more
General okay well let's take uh let's
take this one anyway and complete
our right our thing what do what do you
get for
3234 um ones with
one1
5555 six uh-huh and then this one will
end with a
nine this probably start with ones huh
yeah because it isn't very much bigger
after all it's 111
35569 it's more interesting as well
55 69 69 so there's two fives only wait
a minute this is wrong there's three
threes 11 one
35569 five yeah so I just work out it's
smaller than the previous one yeah it's
um not monotonically increasing
here um sorry 33 34 has more ones than
fives this way
yeah
okay okay yeah cuz that's right this one
has to fit in between those
two oh okay so now it looks so what your
claim is then that like if you got n3s
here then you got n there and N minus
one there okay so now now now but this
other one we say any number threes like
3 three three
three and then two sixes maybe sure are
right just to make sure that it's not
the same as the other one and then a
seven y okay and you and and what's the
square of that supposed five
ones
33s two
FS 3
sixes 28 and a
nine okay wow so we got uh
U five bands of repeating letters
there and uh two parameters m andn i
mean you got three you got M3s
and M
sixs and uh we got five five waves over
there now you've got a proof of that one
no so so what did what did you do uh
this is
we get a new sign called plan ahead
right um what are we uh uh what did you
do make a program that found everything
except when it started to repeat it just
had a limit on how many repeats there
would be or something like that mine was
just brute forest and LU the the first
end but Roger seems to been clever well
it's I don't know Mine mine's just
listing numbers but it seemed to do them
the right order that you see the
patterns but can we get the numbers up
on a on a camera Maybe somebody
can there a way to bring a camera
so look at the numbers I don't
think okay we'll work that out for
another time but anyway so so you got a
table of numbers that looks uh like
Christmas trees here let me let me at
least
show what
they what they look like here and they
have uh you know like lots of threes and
six and sevens
yeah I I noticed something that um after
all the digits of order higher than two
are either one three or
six in in your in in all of your
Solutions or yeah Ah that's an
interesting but I have no proof of that
just that's just in the in the cases
that you
found it it looked like 1 3 and six were
the good digits to have I mean in
N uh yes yeah
okay so that's an
interesting uh thing to to uh wonder why
there's why those are so much more
profit hand Amy you had a comment oh I
was just going to say there's one more
pattern it looks like um a one followed
by some number of sixes and seven also
one okay so you got like one
seven and you got one like that what
does this one come off arbitr many ones
in front of our Trail many sixes oh you
you say you might have a bunch of ones
in front too I think that's true yeah
oh maybe I didn't take it far enough I
don't know let's get this one didn't
show up on
there no I'm just I'm just generalizing
from three-digit number so yeah okay
well no uh so here we got
one six yeah okay work 167
Works 167
1667 okay so now a so this one is this
one appears on on the chart here
2777 8888 9 I think it
is yeah okay so we're we got uh uh
infinitely many solutions and it looks
like the most interesting bunch of this
is going to be the if if we have a two
parameter family of these things but now
the question is how are we going to uh
make sure we've got them all if we have
an infinite number of solutions and uh
uh and is there any reason why these
remarkable coincidences occur I mean
this isn't supposed to happen is
it isn't that amazing that you well with
all the repetition looks like there
should be some kind of pumping Lemma
sort of thing I can I mean I don't know
what it would be okay uh everybody know
what a pumping Lemma is no uh that's
good I uh what's the pumping limit Andy
well I mean it it basically says that
once the strings get Beyond a certain
length you can find a certain part of
the string that can be repeated as many
times as you
want okay um that's uh yeah the idea in
U for example in a
u uh it it comes up in in language
theory that says if you have a a
sufficiently long string
um then you can break it up into like in
context free language if you have a
sufficiently long string uh you can
break it up into parts are like Alpha
Beta
Gamma Delta Epsilon for which you can
beta to the N Gamma Delta to the N
Epsilon is also in the language for all
n um including n equals zero but there
any sufficiently long string in in a
context free language can be can be
written can be broken into fi into
substrings in some way for which uh uh
for which all of these strings are beta
and Delta are not both empty for which
all of these strings are also in the
language and the way they prove that is
is uh is uh well I guess I can give it
because it's fairly it's it's a it's a
fairly uh it might help to our our
solution the way to prove that is uh uh
if you look at the derivation the um the
parts of of of the sufficiently long
string it's bound to use some
non-terminal symbol twice um below
itself some non- terminal is going to
have to be used below itself because if
you because the um the the derivations
that never repeat a non-terminal below
itself are finite so so after you get
past that finite number you're going to
have to have one case where there's some
non-terminal symbol say a uh producing a
and so this this uh this string must
have been produced where a is the one
that's that actually produces beta Gamma
Delta and then it also used itself and
so a also produced gamma and so the
whole parts of this string is a is the
form Alpha a Epsilon is in the language
and so a is also every a is also beta a
Delta and then you can repeat this part
of the derivation over and over again
and get beta to the end Delta to the end
in there so if we had a if we had some
kind of a that so pumping lemon says
that if you have a long enough uh uh
string then there must be that but I I'm
not sure how we would use that in this
case unless we could show that squaring
context free uh operation or something
like that which which um uh would be
really uh I mean it's
a it would really be remarkable if that
were true because uh uh uh squaring
seems to involve carrying and carry
propagation and so on um on the other
hand uh we have a little bit of a since
we're working with monotonic numbers
numbers that are
sorted um
we
uh oh I don't know the carry we still
using carrying in this in order to get
these patterns the carrying is working
in here somehow so I'm not sure how we
could how we could uh get anything
context free to work on that but anyway
pumping lemas are are very important in
in language Theory most mostly for
proving that certain um languages are
not
um uh context fre it tells you a lot
about about U context free
languages I'm not sure how but it looks
like it's coming in here that is we're
getting we're getting patterns that
depend on m&n maybe we maybe we ought to
look further at these threes and sixes
and sevens and see what we
can what if we can
conjecture what the pattern
is that looks like the most uh
uh most curious thing to to to do now so
let's try to get
a a feeling for U for what's going on
and that on that one that's amazing so
first of all we have uh um let's say uh
no threes so that's so so that's the one
I just erased 7 s equal 49 672 = 4489
and so on
okay then uh 37
squared and 367
SAR 3667
squ is something to um look at and then
um
okay
so hi yeah I don't know these uh I can't
prove it but these seem to maybe that's
what you're talking about but these seem
to follow a certain pattern that you
have one starting one then end sixes
then a seven I have got a list
here of the first 50 have you got them
all the first 50 ver
50 so you have 1 followed by n six is
followed by 7 then you have n + 1 3 is
followed by a 4 n + 1 3 is followed by a
5 n + 1 3 is followed by 7 what are the
um um I mean the first
few your your chart shows the just these
are n right and yeah these are just the
NS oh it doesn't show n squ no but n squ
are okay okay now after the first few
mhm okay
uh you what you seem to find is that you
have one followed by n6 followed by 7
yeah okay then n + 1 3 is followed by
4 um 1 followed by n sucess yeah so you
have 3 to the n + 1
four I mean n is any so n plus one means
that you have to have at least 1 three
is that what you mean no I mean after a
certain yeah uh then you have three
three n + 1 3 is followed by five yeah
we had those yeah and s n + 1 3 is
followed by 7
yeah then you have n3s followed by 6
followed by
7 uhhuh then N - 1 3 is followed by 6 by
and so on until you all n +1 6 is
followed by a 7 and then it goes to this
is n like that oh I see you're you're
giving me the numbers uh for large uh
for large numbers of digits okay okay
then you have so this is two sixes here
you mean so yeah yeah then this goes on
until you have n + 1 6 is followed by
seven oh okay so then we get um I see 6
squ and so on so then we find with 3 0 6
to the n + 1 7 7 and then it becomes 1
followed by 6 is is n plus then we come
back to here again yeah that's what
you're saying so that uh claim is that
we have listed on the board already all
of the infinite families I don't know
but I have looked at say for three four
for lens of 3 four five M so this this
works up to in other words this is this
is the pattern after after the first uh
few little uh cases of how about the any
number of ones followed by sixes and
sevens so somebody say doesn't that's
right we got we have counter 1167
doesn't count
okay okay but 116 does but and 117 but
they uh but after that it's not listed
on this on this
chart okay so after after we get to a
sufficiently high point this seems to be
what the conjecture is now we just we
have have to prove it then we might be
able to prove this without a computer
that's too
bad we'll have to do something with a
program oh maybe not we generated it
with the program what we generated this
numbers that's okay right yeah good I I
don't quite understand the conjecture
but okay well we we have to we uh the
conjecture is that after you start out
and and throw away all all solutions
where n is less than um a th000 or
something like that then what are the N
Plus 2digit numbers look
like it's it's 1 1667 3334 3335 3337
3367 uh
3667 667 and then you go to the five
digigit numbers five digigit numbers
would be oh I see with n equals 3
here and and uh then the six digigit
numbers and so on
okay right so so uh I mean this is the
conjecture is not only that all of these
work but that none others do for large
enough uh
and is that clear so that that uh uh the
uh uh you know for the small case we had
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 they all work then 12 13
15 16 17 so there's these sporadic ones
that but then after a while they seem to
be doing and it says recording
terminated Thursday 10th January 10:59
a.m. no wonder you were a little late
for
class well for proving that they all
work you can probably use the same
technique by induction that Anil did and
then for proving that none others work
didn't we have a kind of theorem
that ax didn't have that property unless
X had that property use the technique we
started with
yesterday okay right going back to what
we said yesterday we had to we could we
could exhaust uh on on the possibilities
for for coming back yeah that's a good
good thing right now I'd like to I'd
like to first see if we can't find what
this pattern is of the of the right hand
sides of with the threes and sixes
because this is a double family here
where we have two two parameters and uh
um uh it would it would be interesting
to have a conjecture as to what as to
what these are going to be in fact
um um I must say I didn't expect such
such a rich family of solutions uh with
two independent parameters uh but it
seems that it might might be true um so
what is 37
squ 1369 excuse me oh I got him here
maybe 13 69
1369 and then two
ones oh oh mean 1 one 1 1
3569 find the pattern in this no no
that's not that's for 35 37 sry oh this
one mhm one one three no uh both numbers
I
gave what where for 337 and 336 oh this
is the
1369 and this is 113 5
no no no sorry can I give you the
numbers from the beginning maybe you
should write
them it's important to have some good
data yeah okay for 37 squ mhm it's
okay for 3 for 337 it's 1 1
3569 okay
for 33 67 is one 1 1 3
3 66 8
four no no
no do have this one 36 36 7 is 134 689 1
34 1
34689 U any any other data
here 3667 I got on this
chart from um Rogers is
13 4 4 6 8 8
and 33
667 is 1
one 3 3 4 6 6 88
9 okay well you guys figure out the
pattern while I'm writing out the next
line
here this one
we
for
I think the problem on the last column
is that you started the pattern one too
early the first one doesn't fit
in uhhuh so so uh we
we uh that that's a member of a
different class we have an anom yeah
okay so uh uh it looks like in other
words you're getting here we getting
uh uh four fours
38 okay well um why don't we
uh uh try to get some algebraic
explanation for what's for what's going
on what is that what's what is a a
number like this uh and
uh uh in general for for General n uh
can we write 6 to the N
7 um is equal to Something in close form
4 to the N yeah 4 the N excuse me the n
in the same notation no no no I'm sorry
I meant uh I I mean what is this equal
to as far as uh uh a closed form in in
um uh see when I write 6 to the n what I
mean
is 2 * 10 n- 1 + 1 /
3 okay 2 it's like 2/3 so it's 2 * 10 N
- 1 2 * 10 n- no nus one n is the
nus n n n+ one yeah plus one so that we
balance the seven so it's not really too
the whole thing divid about TR okay like
that and uh uh that's like 2/3 okay so
that's a that's a formula for it it
suggests that we multiply by three and
see what what three times uh these
numbers is right so suppose we have
something like three M of those and six
n of these and then seven and we
multiply by three
uh then we might find out what this what
this number is um in some other form and
then we can we can um uh Square it and
and divide out by
nine so
um 3 * 7 is
21 uh carry the two 3 * 6 20 get down
zeros is uh yeah 3 * 6 is uh is 18 and
carry of two is 20 so we keep carrying
so we get zero to the end with with a
carry of two out to the next batch right
three * uh 3 is N9 carry two is one
carry
one and then 3 then we got nus one nus
one
zeros and one okay so um uh there we've
got a formula for three times uh this
guy in the left right okay so so 3x is
that which is a fairly easy number to
square okay so let's call let's say
let's say x is equal to this 3x is equal
to this what is
3x²
um well that's 10 to the
m
+ what well we got 10 to the N plus
something + 1 quantity squared what is
the uh let's see we got n + one
here how many digits are there to the
right of this
one n plus n +
one
okay so um this this is now 10 the 2 m +
2 n +
plus
um uh 2
* 10 to the what m + 2 n +
2 um then we get um
plus uh
two times 10 the 2 or what is it m + n +
1 it's these
terms and we got this
term squared so there's sticking in here
somewhere is um 10
the 2 n +
2 and
um and then we got two
10 the n + 1 +
so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 nine yeah so there
ought to be nine nine things in there
okay so now we don't
know where where this um this guy is
sort of a Maverick he uh depends on
whether m is bigger than n or not as to
where it fits in to the uh uh to the
answer but that might not matter if we
divide by nine now notice that this
number is um uh is uh a multiple of nine
we know it is because it's 3x squ um but
also you can look at the sum of its
digits uh its digits are 1 2 2 1 2 and
one and you know that a number is a
multiple of nine if its digits that up
to
nine so we got we got that okay now
let's see um this
Blackboard works okay with yellow chalk
so I'll try that so so divide that
number by nine and we got x s so x
s is equal
to
um so
uh well need some notation for strings
of the first one's going to be 2 n + 2 N
plus 2 1es okay yeah that's an that's an
interesting uh uh Point Mike that uh
let's suppose we have for example one to
the end uh this is a number that's
called a rep unit I guess in uh by you
know there's a there's a study of rep
units and this is this is the name of a
and uh uh one of the uh you know
something like meren primes uh there are
question is what rep unit primes are
there I think if you have 17 of them you
get a prime or something like that and
nobody knows where there's infinitely
many rep unit primes but this is uh um
uh this is 10 to the N - 1
9 now if if a number is sorted so let's
call this um um R sub n for rep
unit um that's a general thing in
problem solving uh is uh if you if you
if you think you're going to use certain
quantity many times try to have a name
for it uh uh name and Conquer or
something like that um and and you see
in all of our in in all of our uh uh
things here this this 6 to the N 7 we
could have called that 6 R sub n + 1 + 1
also um see what I mean because uh uh
that's a that's a six times a rep unit
is all
sixes and um uh the nice thing about
numbers that are sorted is what
you can write them easily in terms of
rep units for example 1
3 4 4 4 6 8 8 8 9 is equal to R sub 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 R sub 10 plus 2 R sub n
plus 2 R sub
plus r sub 8 plus 2 R
sub 5 5 plus r
sub 2 R sub 4 + r sub one which is not
which is one okay so so um uh numbers
that are monotonic are in fact you can
write them as a sum of of rep units uh
times positive integers the sum of all
the positive integers or non- negative
integers I'm sorry this is 0 r70 R six
fits in there so you know another
representation for this is sort of uh uh
the differencing notation uh one 2 1 0 0
76 5
4 3
2 one like that so the differences of
these numbers uh 4 - 3 4 - 4 6 - 4 and
so on U give you another another sort of
a notation for the for the number uh
where this represents a coefficient in
terms of rep
units
um also
um
um this is
like since we since we got this
coefficient one here by taking 4 minus 3
and this coefficient Z by taking this
digit minus this digit what we're really
doing is uh
um shifting right one and
subtracting and uh shifting right one is
and subtracting is uh
um is is enough to give us this notation
then so so uh we started out with x uh
this is why is x² this is um then um
Yus y I /
10 um taking the uh the integer part
because we're throwing away the the
remainder is equal to 1
221 and this is
approximately one uh what is it um 9/10
of of Y multiply by okay now um anyway
we got
this this formula and
x^2 um or or
3x^2 is equal
to uh
R of um what 2 m + 2
N that might not be the right way to go
* excuse me it's 9 * uh plus one because
you have one Follow by so many zeros
over there oh okay so so uh um you
wanted after you divide by
n yeah I see after yeah what I want is
to divide by nine and so um um it would
be real nice if I didn't have all these
powers of 10 but they were all all minus
ones after them right let's put them
in add it back in again
later okay now this one I'll take up my
one there okay I got to add in two there
I know how many I'm going to add in
right I'm going to add nine Al together
so I'm going to take them out one at a
time aren't you going to add in eight
because the last one you don't need that
the one at the bottom you don't need to
do that that's true we're still going to
divide I I I'll I'll I'll take it out
though
anyway this eraser isn't very good okay
so
up
okay all right now now it's right so so
now now we can divide by 9 and um we can
get x s and see what it is so x x is
equal to R
sub
m r sub m + 2 n +
2 that right
plus 2 R sub m + 2 n +
2 and so on nice R sub m +
n + 1 plus r sub 2 n + 2 need a
coefficient need a coefficient of two on
the third this guy yeah okay R sub um n
+
1 and then um + one at the
end 9 over 9 is one right which is
R1
uh and uh so now we have
uh 2 4 6 7 8 9 so now we
have expressed this as a as a as a uh
sum of of of rep units with non-
negative
coefficients and the total number of
these coefficients is less than 10 the
sum of all these coefficients is less
than 10 that's equivalent to being a a
sorted number let's state that again
clearly right a number is sorted if and
only if you can write
it as a sum of RS of at most uh let
let's let me uh even um leave out the
coefficients and by and just duplicate
allow allow duplicates
here all
right uh I didn't realize that before
before class today but that's a nice
characterization so now we take up to
nine RS and add them together and you
got a sorted number and
conversely every sorted number is a sum
of up to 9 RS okay so here we
got nine RS so it must be it must be uh
uh a rep unit we don't need to prove it
by induction
in fact
okay
um all right that's interesting now the
the U
um uh anybody can anybody see why it
might be that we
had uh let's see is it is it likely that
we would be able to do this uh that both
n and N2 would be would be uh uh
expressible in this form um why
is there any sort of a reason for this
yeah this is this is exactly the dead
end I was talking about I got this far
but you just get uh you just get an
equation with you know 10 to the N plus
n y represented slightly differently but
um you need to find a necessary and
sufficient constraints that tell you um
when when you do just get nine um rep
units right I don't see how to do that
okay so we still haven't shown the other
way why you what why don't you um but
the but one of the things that strikes
me about it is that is that uh uh the
rep unit
um is dividing by
nine and
um nine is a perfect
square um in other words uh dividing by
three gives us also rep
units uh somehow the fact that
three that that the the the three worked
here but other numbers didn't not not
like what I'm what I'm thinking is this
suppose we're working in base 8
arithmetic then our rep units would be
defined by you know 8 nus 1/
7 and um uh so we could we could see
what what sort of numbers were but when
you square those uh chances are small
that you're going to get any that that
you're going to get anything nice out of
it but somehow the fact that fact is
that we when we took um a number that
here here was a number when we multipied
it by three um uh uh was a uh could be
expressed easily in terms of of powers
of uh of
um so that's uh uh
um well then X over3 could be expressed
as rep
units um so the the somehow 3^2 being
equal to minus1 in our base being equal
to to 10 - 1 is uh is is I think the
reason why we're getting a coincidence
here while we're getting these these
these infinite patterns so probably if
you tried this for for base 8 you would
find a finite number of patterns I bet
you I don't know
I triy looking at bases two and three
you don't get any non tribal Solutions
base two is kind of odd so is is all
ones and so the uh uh so you need a
perfect square that's a of the form on
so in base five which has 5 four a
perfect Bas five we would expect
something okay so now uh I want to come
back to what Karen mentioned and uh Andy
U few minutes ago is is uh is uh in
order to in order to see if we're if in
order to show that there aren't any more
uh we will would like to do some kind of
a uh uh exhaustive method that says that
there's nothing else to do that that
going from right to left um uh that says
that we that uh we um uh have found all
the Solutions in this way
so any ideas on how to actually program
that
like yeah
AR the the way we program this thing to
to find out the the actual values what
one does is start off with smaller
strings and go on to larger ones perhaps
we could examine the smallest I mean you
you start pruning the ones which will
not lead to any further results
obviously so uh one maybe one could
examine the strings which one gets after
a certain point and see if they form a a
certain pattern maybe you can an
induction so for example you would you
you would have some way of cutting off
and saying that uh that uh uh let me see
if I understand what you said you you
you you would uh go exhaustively
until until something happens like you
got lots of Threes in a row or something
like that and then you say okay I'm not
going to I'm not going to consider I
I've already seen that it works with
with 20 83 is now I'm not going to try
29 because I assume that no I not
talking about that okay what I was
saying is that maybe at some point one
with the pruning you you'll get to a a
regular some some kind of set of
patterns which is some kind of regular
set regular I don't mean in the grammar
sense but in some some fixed pattern and
then maybe you can uh do some kind of
induction on that to show that the next
set of patterns you'll get will also be
of this form and therefore the solutions
which you get it must always be of this
form do you want the computer to do this
induction no I was talking about that's
what I was getting at you you you'll you
the computer will will stop and say hm
this is interesting help me or or or
this is this suggests a conjecture maybe
you can do this by hand um yeah we could
also Imagine of course uh the computer
uh uh being pre-programmed to uh uh with
all all ideas of mathematics in it
and to to follow along every conjecture
um or we could uh imagine that we could
pre-program it for a small class of
conjectures that it that it might be
able to uh uh that it might be able to
dispense of
automatically right so so uh uh in your
case you those numbers that you showed
me how did you get them you well I was
essentially doing almost the same kind
of thing that you did that day except
that I had a slightly easier way of
finding out whether the whether that a
was possible or not M essentially what
you find is that uh the next digit of
the
square uh let me put it this way
supposing you have 3 3 3 3 4 as your
base let's say okay okay and uh now you
are looking for
a334 okay okay and you are trying to
find out what are the possible values of
a right okay so 334 squ has a certain
value in it's fourth place that is okay
so um happen to know oh we don't have
that one anymore I got it here
yeah actually there's a program in there
as well if you want yeah
334 334 squar is is uh
something uh okay so well um
last 3342 is equal to and and you've
already check generated uh uh this is
something
556 okay so what you find is that 8 a
that is 2 * 4 3 3 4 so take the units
please you find 88 + uh
1 must uh must be less than or equal to
five all right so um so now the idea is
and then this is this is uh um equal to
um 556
and and 8
a
ignoring ignoring everything to the left
and so this is going to come out like
this and here it'll be 8 a + 1 right
oops floppy 8 a +
1 essentially all right yeah now this is
modul of 10 and so we just keep
checking so now that tiet has to be
either
a uh okay it's going to be odd and it
shouldn't be zero it and if and if it
were zero then we would uh uh yeah be be
stuck huh so it should be between one
and
five okay what if it were first of all
if a if alpha or a is zero then we have
to check if the number we
have there's a yeah there's a uh a
possibility that we've got a bunch of
zeros out here yeah there has to be
another already checked yeah okay you're
trying to find
a okay right so a so anyway this this
number in this case will will certainly
be odd and uh and uh that's
um
uh has to be 103 that works fine okay so
I mean essentially it's just a slightly
simpler form of finding out what what
what other set of patterns it can be and
you essentially have some kind of a
search tree so
now
um uh yeah the search tree in other
words is is it it works digit by digit
and considers every so here we have
several cases we can make this equal to
five three or one by choosing a
different ways and uh a on the other
hand um has to be less than or equal
three and so that'll also constrain our
search what if we what if I asked for
the harder problem
all n s that were sorted but forget
about n being
sorted what if I what if I had
asked for that
um only mean that instead of a being
between 1 and 3 you could take a between
1 and 9 yep and so I could I could go on
here uh with with lots of fives and and
I could and I would have uh two choices
for a um say to make this equal to five
usually a and a + 5 both give the same
the same
result that right A and A + 5 with a + 5
if if if you put another five in
here
um uh can can anybody tell me what what
this does to the you know it it changes
this digit but it
also it also changes the next digit um
see what's happening is if you take x +
5,000
squar that gives you x^2
plus um
10,000x
plus some you know some huge number of
zeros and so if I change a suppose a is
a well to make a SQL of five what do we
got to do a a a is um 8 a + 1 is 5 that
means 8 a is 4 mod 10 that's 4 a is I'm
sorry 8 a is four that's 4 a is uh 2 a
is one so a is
two A a is
um oh I'm sorry I can't divide out
twice he is three or eight a is three or
eight okay so so in the case of three
three um uh that's a good one of course
we know that this pattern is going to go
on if a is eight then um what's
happening is we're
adding um something to our next over
um if this is an odd number then this
will make the next this will change the
evenness or oddness of the
next
okay uh let's see now to to continue
then
um uh for for next week
um I think that uh there are some a few
more things interesting to say about
this problem but not probably two
sessions worth so why don't we have why
don't we figure on wrapping up this
problem next Tuesday unless some people
have a find something real interesting
about it by then uh uh more and then
we'll begin on problem two we have that
much more time for the uh for the other
problems if we if we can uh if somebody
however solves the problem of finding
all sorted values of
n^2 uh then uh then that would open up a
whole new a range of
ideas let's see I think I ought to
finish one more piece of old business
before we quit today and that is we
never did put X into into rep unit form
so we had 3x was this so 3x is
um is 10 to
the m + n +
1 got there + 10 n + 1 + 1 uh which is
equal to 10 the n + n +
1 -1 10 the N +1
-1 um uh plus 3 okay so therefore X is
equal to R sub m + n + 1 plus r sub n +
1 plus um sorry three of
these um right divide
by yeah X is equal to 1/3 of that which
is three 13 that and 13 that plus
one so there's our X and um and there's
our X squ so that's the completion of
that of that formulas is it the last one
r0 instead of
R1 yeah what what about that how many
ones are there in R
subn how many ones are there in in R
subn
let's there are n ones in R subn and so
so there would be zero ones in R sub
Z but weren't you getting a zero by plus
one minus one yeah this is the the the
what's known as the fence post error or
or um uh I I I
can't I can't be sure of all my formulas
because I do make errors but uh uh when
when I got one I think R R1 is one I
believe that that I can claim but
because see the uh I I I went to one
more place
uh to 10 to the n in order to get n
zeros after it yeah so r0 is uh 10 0 -1
over 9 which is zero so so U uh I was
attempted to also say this say r z but
uh I think it's our
one Arie you have
okay so um uh I think the main thing to
solve then between now and and next time
is whether or not it's easy to to uh
prove these conjectures uh in the
computer that is instead of having the
computer just just uh uh spew out the U
uh uh saying this looks like it might be
a pattern that works and then uh uh uh
and then exhaustively disprove all the
other ones um it would be nice if the
computer could also verify the good ones
because we have a a small number of
technique of Tricks that'll probably
suffice to to verify it and uh so why
not try other bases than 10 see see uh
if base 17 in fact does have some
interesting uh uh families of solutions
because we can do this with other bases
uh then with this with the same
techniques we use for this one uh
that'll be that'll be a test of whether
the Thing Really Works
that's not a proof excuse me that's not
a proof what's not a proof I mean if you
even if you could generate numbers like
that on base 17 or whatever and get
similar families
yeah that's not a proof that this family
is correct that's not a family that the
which family that is not a proof that
this family is exhaustive I mean that
this and okay uh what I what I believe
you do is something like this you have a
you have a
tree like as you
suggested that that uh uh has has two
ways to come one is whether when you
drop to a to to another digit or not now
when the tree when the tree has a choice
of staying at the same digit it could
try to generate a conjecture saying I
stay at this digit nend
times and then I drop down so if you
could generate a conjecture uh uh then
you could you could uh uh you know if if
you would have to find some way of
proving that that conjecture can be
handled for end times um and maybe the r
subn notation works for uh to to to work
on that on that conjecture um it's not
it's not um it's not immediately clear
that it will work but I think it might
um uh but the the main thing about you
tree method is that when you finally do
drop from a from a digit to a lower
digit then you know you've made some
progress and eventually you you you you
have no more
choices and you and uh uh so it has to
be a perfect square or
not okay any other comments I
know Andy what do you
think um well there might be some way of
having yeah making kind of treating them
pruning off some of the branches to make
trying to make a minimal subset or
and yeah interesting like like the
conjecture that came up with uh you know
putting a number of ones in front it
started out looking good and then all of
a sudden it didn't work and so uh uh the
uh it I think it'd be interesting to see
how if a computer could really discover
all of these
Solutions instead of just uh letting us
uh with all our wisdom and our and our
algebraic facility uh do it maybe uh the
the kinds of tricks that are needed to
solve to to prove these problems are um
are sufficiently simple that we can do
it and I think uh having a name for for
having this characterization a finite
sum of up to n
RS is a is is the the way to uh the
easiest way to uh uh to make make a
proof in the positive direction to make
a disproof that there aren't any other
cases it's just a tree going through the
possibilities and coming to dead ends
yeah okay thanks a
lot